les deux femmes se connaissent bien
neuf ans déjà depuis l'annnonce du
cancer de denise et l'ablation de son
sein droit
depuis elles fréquentent régulièrement
le showroom de sonia prothésiste ma mère
au point d'y être à l'aise comme chez
elle oui aujourd'hui de nice vient pour
un soutien gorge noir une lingerie
spécialisés qui comporte une poche dans
laquelle on insère la prothèse mammaire
un produit adapté à sa nouvelle
morphologie
le résultat est bluffant de son propre
aveu le moment le plus difficile pour
denise après l'annoncé de son cancer du
sein en 2010 a été la découverte du vide
laissé par l'ablation ma mère par la
suite elle a choisi de ne pas revenir
sur la table d'opération pour faire
reconstruire son sein alors j'ai
plusieurs potez d'accord et je change en
fonction de la tenue que j'essaie j'ai
une robe décolletée j'ai le soutien sans
bretelles qui va à une prothèse spéciale
six jeunes roms ça dépend là plusieurs
fautes et protège à la maison oui je
suis très à l'aise jeux sont même pas
soyez à l'aise car elle possède aussi
des prothèses carnet qui se rapproche de
sa couleur de fou indispensable dans les
moments d'intimité quand on veut être
sexy ou simplement pour poser un autre
regard sur soi même
détail d'importance le mamelon silicone
teintées lui aussi qui peut se rajouter
à la prothèse quand elle n'en possède
pas ou directement sur le sein
reconstruit
quand on ne veut pas subir une opération
supplémentaire alexandre harnais la
présidente de l'association amazon
martinique se souvient encore de sa
première prothèse offerte avant sa
sortie de l'hôpital de nantes
celle qui faisait d'elle un zèbre comme
elle en sourit elle même avec le recul
j'ai pas tilté sur le coup c'est encore
moins donner une autre thèse blanche
enfin pour une femme à pau blanche
je n'ai pas réalisé sur le coup enfin
dans un premier temps on cherche surtout
à remplir un peu l'autre côté du
soutien-gorge et puis en rentrant en
martinique
parce que j'ai été soigné à la fois en à
nantes et en martinique j'ai rencontré
madame ditto et là hop surprise je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait des
prothèses pour les chats been pour les
[__] pour les métis enfin pour tout
type de peau également pour les femmes
blanches et j'ai réalisé que n'ose phase
s'était pas normal d'accepter ça comme
ça pour alexandra c'est un signe évident
de l'invisibilité des personnes noires
dans cette maladie et dans les thérapies
qui leur sont proposées une invisibilité
contre laquelle sonia guito a voulu
lutter dès ses débuts dans le métier
d'orthopédistes elle est la seule dans
son créneau en martinique
la première appli catrice de l'île
dûment formés de la prothèse en mousse
postopératoire à la prothèse contact en
silicone elle a voulu proposer aux
femmes noires des produits qui leur
ressemble et au début il a fallu
commander ses prothèses inexistante
jusqu'à l'or sur le marché
encore aujourd'hui elle vienne n'ont pas
de france mais d'allemagne j'avais fait
faire pour défaut thèse a marre on va
dire ma roue puisque nous sommes deux
couleurs différentes
donc nous avons déposé adapté donc on
peut les enfants sans problème j'ai un
stock
peut-être par toutes les tailles mais
j'ai dit stop je vais faire au moins
quantité psychologiquement ça fait du
bien parce que quand on se regarde dans
un miroir et on voit les deux seins
pareille surtout si j'achète j'achète
mamelons donc c'est l'idéal
donc on se redécouvre environ 20 femmes
viennent ici chaque mois retrouver
l'estimé l'amour de leur corps après un
cancer du sein certaines pour la
première fois d'autres pour étoffer leur
équipement lingerie ou en prothèses
mammaires dans son domaine sonia guito a
été une pionnière il ya plus de 30 ans
elle a baptisé son showroom la maison du
bonheur
à l'affût